I can I get asked all the time if you
could only use one supplement what would
it be and my answer is inevitably
athletic greens it is your all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
in the 4-hour body did not get paid for
that and I travel with it to avoid
getting sick I take it in the mornings
to ensure optimal performance it just
covers all my bases if I can't get what
I need through whole food meals
throughout the rest of the day if you
want to give athletic greens to try they
are offering a free 20 count travel pack
for first-time users I always travel
with at least three or four of these
this represents a $100 value so if you
buy athletic greens you get an extra
$100 and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash tim
again that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase this episode is
brought to you by fresh books fresh
books has become the go-to cloud
accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advised and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast their new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free super
easy late payment reminders so you don't
have to chase people automatic expenses
sharing files and messages with your
clients award-winning customer service
they are extremely responsive the
interface is super intuitive and there's
almost no learning curve so in short
it's easy it saves you time and right
now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash Tim and enter Tim Ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell tea IM f e RR is s
so again go to fresh books calm forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss and how
did you hear about us section check it
out hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers
people are the best at what they do
duties out then habits routines life
lessons favorite books favorite cooking
pans and so on that you can use in that
last little bit with some heavy
foreshadowing for this episode my guest
today is Samina no Scott you can find
her at Chow sameen CIA Oh at just me and
on instagram and twitter facebook
forward slash Cimino's rot and the
website is salt fat acid heat calm which
we'll be getting into and sameen is
amazing she is a writer a chef and a
teacher in my mind first and foremost
absolutely masterful teacher and
excellent at turning complexity into
simplicity her New York Times
best-selling at first book salt fat acid
heat received the James Beard Award
that's like at the Oscars Best Picture
for best general cookbook and it was
named cookbook of the Year by the
International Association of culinary
professionals but this episode is about
so much more than just cooking it is
about the creative process it is about
creative highest creative lows pushing
through rejection you name it it's very
very vulnerable if you liked the Brandon
stand an episode you are going to love
this episode
and it covers some heavy stuff some
really important stuff but back to the
bio semion has been called quote the
next Julia Child and quote by NPR's all
things considered and she has been
cooking professionally since 2000 when
she first stumbled into the kitchen at
blank blank blank we're gonna cover with
that blank blank blank is an iconic
restaurant that no doubt you've heard of
and what an amazing Genesis story it is
a neat columnist for The New York Times
magazines I mean lives cooks reads and
Gardens in Berkeley California her
latest project is absolutely gorgeous it
is a Netflix original documentary series
that may sound familiar salt fat acid
Heat same title as the book produced by
jigsaw productions and I heavily heavily
recommend that you check it out it is
absolutely gorgeous salt fat acid Heat
on Netflix so without further ado please
enjoy this very wide-ranging very
vulnerable and to my mind very important
conversation with sameen dose right
Simon welcome to the show thanks for
having me Tim and I I know that people
are gonna say wait a second he just
mispronounced her name and I want them
to know that I double and triple checked
it with you beforehand a lot of people
say sameen because that would be English
friendly but the correct pronunciation
of your full name is what is I mean yeah
you're going you're you've like
graduated past the appropriate American
pronunciation into your going for true
persian right now you know i will get
there i will get there and I struggled
with deciding where to begin topically
this conversation but one thing really
jumped out at me and I wanted to begin
there since I like to follow my interest
and that is the manifestation journal
can you tell me about your manifestation
journal
I'm so happy you're asking so I don't
know where the idea for my manifestation
journal came from I think it may have
been like a self-help blog
approximately 2008 but it's just a
notebook that I bought it in like art
supply store it's just a sketchbook and
I just decided to start writing down the
things that I envisioned for my life at
whether they were really big and I would
ever be like too embarrassed to
articulate them to anyone or whether
they were really little and I tried I
sort of knew initially that I should be
as specific as possible and what's
pretty bananas is sometimes I'll
misplace the journal like it'll slide
under my bed and I'll forget about it
for I don't know six months or something
and then I'll pull it out I think at one
point I lost it for about two years and
I'll pull it out and I'll look and I'll
be like oh my gosh like word for word so
many of these things have happened you
know and I think and there are also many
things in there that have not come true
yet or like maybe I was misguided and I
changed and goals shifted but it is
really sort of mind-blowing to go back
and look at how specific goals sort of
come to life when you plant a seed you
know that you achieve things when you
plant a seed and you're really clear
about it and I've always known that and
I've always really adhered to that and
so it's just one little practice that I
have at this point I like to look at it
around my birthday and around the new
year those are sort of the two times of
year that I pretty diligently will check
in and write into it but it's not you
know it's not a big thing that I do all
the time but it is really incredible
especially as I've started to sort of
achieve bigger goals in my career to go
back and look at it and say wow like I
wanted always to write for this
publication and now I am or I really
specifically wanted you know a book deal
with a certain amount of money and I
achieved it and you know and it's yeah
well I've so many follow-up questions
because I'm a nerd when it comes to
journaling and notebooks and it's
something that that comes up a fair
amount in this podcast from profile in
the California Sunday magazine this was
discussed in a few lines and when the
the interviewer in this case flipped
through the notebook which I'm jealous
immediately it it gave a few examples as
next in quote next two small candid
instructions to herself example chin
hairs under control exclamation point
and general life notions in parentheses
bay leaf pinata exclamation point not
sure of that but that's okay welcome
back that there were goals that I found
striking in their precision go to Italy
write and publish at least one story in
prints start writing her first book
those were dated 2008 and all have come
true so my question is when you were do
you still use the journal if so
generally speaking say from 2008 forward
how frequently do you write in the
journal and then what does the review
process look like I do still use it
I probably write in it two or three
times a year and I also probably look at
it two or three times a year and it's a
treat to look at it now it's become this
amazing treat where where I get to go
back and see did something happen you
know did I achieve something or did some
thought or notion that I had had at some
time come true and it really is and
often it's a nice thing to sort of help
me refocus where I'm headed I feel like
with my career in a lot of ways it's out
of really what's the word I was gonna
say like a more fifth shape but there
has not been one super clear goal or one
super clear path that I can model my
career on there are in a lot of other
writer chef teacher you know often
people are just write about food or just
cook or just teach and so I have done
all those things and more and I've
always just followed my gut and that can
be really overwhelming because I get
really distracted quite easily by shiny
objects you know or like a lot of money
or the opportunity to work with somebody
or make a decision because of I'm
worried what will happen if I say no and
so I feel like the clearer I am about
what I do want to do the more easily I
can say no or or just make it better too
about where I'm headed so even just a
couple times a year having like a little
bit of quiet time and usually I'll pick
up the thing a couple days before my
birthday and start thinking about like
what I've done in the past year wear
what I wear you know good choices I've
made bad choices I've made and yeah I
and it sort of is a nice sort of
personal check-in I don't know there's a
million names for these things I don't
know why I wrote manifestation journal
but it really is that like you know it's
also just like a journal I don't yeah
when you look at when you look at a page
is it date and then under that just a
series of bullets for things that you
hope to achieve yeah I mean if I were a
little more organized there would
probably be like some sort of method to
the math but it's you know it started
out as bullets and the other day I was
telling somebody I was reading some of
the ones for the very first page for
someone and then I was saying how oh
there's all these things like I don't
know um publish four books you know
popular well reviewed books that I'm
proud of by good well-known publishing
houses and then in at the very bottom in
tiny tiny writing like so small I could
barely admit it to myself and I
certainly can't believe I'm about to
tell you but I wrote in the tiniest
writing MacArthur Genius grant like I
can't believe it's just so embarrassing
and then yeah I wrote I had a page for
long-term goals I had a page for what I
hoped to do that year ideas oh there's
the bay leaf pinata which was I wanted
to make a pinata that was covered
instead of with crepe paper with Bailey
of sewing you hit it with a baseball bat
it smells really good if you're looking
at this journal picking it up three
times a year let's say two or three
times a year is the significance that
you are planting a seed in your
subconscious more so because it sounds
like you're not going back and sort of
reviewing it and some type of
spreadsheet fashion looking at
progress towards the end goal in each of
these cases you're you're visiting it
two or three times a year is is the
importance then that you're planting a
seed in your subconscious that will
somehow very subtly direct your choices
in a different fashion I know that that
a number of people have been on this
podcast my friend Josh Waitzkin who is
the basis for searching for bobby
fisher' Reed Hoffman do quite a bit of
intention setting or journaling either
right before bed or first thing upon
waking up which has that flavor to it
but why do you think this has had an
impact in your life if it has had an
impact I definitely think this lines up
with the idea of planting a seed in my
subconscious and also helping me like
remain accountable to myself and then I
also have all manner of other intention
setting and goal making and list making
just at my office above my desk I have
lists of you know actually adds funny I
had a list of interviews I would like to
do and yours was on the list right and
so I looked at my list I looked at that
list you know every day I went to work
and sat at my computer there's a list
right next to that of maybe projects I
would like to do right and then right
next to that is a list of collaborators
I would like to have you know and
there's people on there like wildly I
sort of just stopped being embarrassed
at some point about having what seemed
wildly unachievable dreams or you know I
put Issa Rae and Ava Duvernay on that
list do I know them is there any
possibility that you know I don't know
like what do I know I just put them on
there because they're people I would
like to maybe work with whose work I
respect and so there is I just had to
stop being afraid that someone would
come into my office and so for a while
when I first started writing the book I
wrote
visualize Oprah's Book Club and I had
that on a post-it note about my dad for
years but and also I don't think she
puts cookbooks on but you know I've
never dare I wouldn't say I've ever been
embarrassed to dream big
and I think the better I have gotten at
articulating my dreams in words and then
really just being mindful of them and
whether it means coming back to them
once or twice a year or looking at them
everyday I do feel like it makes a
difference and it helps me stay on track
and then if I look at that list and
after a while some goal or some name or
some idea doesn't feel right anymore I
can cross it off you know I don't know
it's just um it's a nice thing
especially when I'm in the you know in
the sort of rock bottom part of the
creative process like where you're just
sort of doing the drag the boring stuff
you're doing the counting you're doing
the like terrible writing that's not
coming out easily it's just nice to look
up and be like oh yes I am a creative
person who has big ideas and you know
sometimes makes things happen so I don't
know it's not it's like a little bit of
cheerleading for myself I guess when
this is really important so I want to
explore it for a moment this and this is
going to be very non chronological we're
gonna bounce all over the place
I do have questions about San Diego but
we're going to come to that first eat
since you said the rock bottom of the
creative process so when you are in the
rock bottom of the creative process and
almost anyone except for a few mutants
here there who just seem to always
operate in the proper gear but for most
people with any large or unfamiliar
creative project there's going to be
maybe one rock bottom maybe many
different rock bottom difficult moments
do you use anything we're talking about
in some ways future tents the things you
want to do when you're in that rock
bottom place do you use anything from
the past things you've achieved or
milestones you've accomplished or
anything from the present tense to also
help buoy your spirits or is it mostly
the keeping your eye on the ball that is
ahead of you that future tense that
helps you
I think I wish that I think I need some
more therapy and meditation to get to be
the kind of person who can feel good
about my past accomplishments and let
them buoy me too to buoy me forward I
think I sort of achieved the thing and
then I forget about it like it's even
part hard for me when I receive praise I
get so many emails all the time which
are so meaningful in a way these are
maybe the most meaningful kind of
feedback that I get is from people who
are like I read your book and now I cook
vegetables for my kids and they eat them
you know and it tastes good and that
kind of stuff is really I think the most
powerful for me but still there's a way
where I'm like oh somebody else did that
I and it's really hard for me to accept
praise or really fully feel in my body
pride and happiness at having achieved
these like goals I have listed on papers
all over the place so I do a lot of work
in therapy and meditation and just like
you know trying to be better about my
body and connecting with my body and
feeling that stuff so here up until now
I have not historically used those
things to get me through the creative
lows I often once I I do have to sort of
keep my eye on the prize I think in
therapy and in just my own life I have
had to do a lot of work in reframing
what success means and what it looks
like so that as I work toward
quote-unquote success I'm working
towards something that will be positive
for me rather than can then also beat me
down like I'm a crazy perfectionist
child of immigrants who you know like
was raised in a family where nothing was
ever good enough nothing I did was ever
like perfect you know it was just i'm
perfectionist from childhood and then I
entered a profession and in particular
like began working in an institution
which is run by like a world-class
perfectionist and so nothing that any of
us ever did was good enough which is
good because it keeps us pushing all
toward doing better but I haven't
historically had a lot of
positive feedback and really allowed
myself to feel that so I'm doing a lot
of my own work to sort of be proud at
the things that I do whether they're
perfect quote unquote
or just good enough or whatever and you
know I had a lot of fear before my book
was released that because it was the
biggest project that I had ever worked
on it was a lot the longest dream that I
had ever worked toward I had put
everything I had into it and because it
took me so long to do a lot of people at
least I felt the pressure of a lot of
people looking at me and at this book
and people were waiting for it and I
knew they were ready to respond in
whatever way right I didn't know what
way and I have always you know you like
worked for external praise and I'm aware
of that and so I went to therapy and I
told my therapist I said I'm really
worried that when this book comes out
that I am going to sort of sink or swim
on the worlds reception of it and I
don't want to do that so how do I get
out of that how do I exist in a way
where whatever the reception is of this
thing I will still be okay and not like
break into 1 million pieces and so he
said well we have to create a definition
of success that's on your terms so it
took me a lot of months on a lot of
thinking and eventually I came back to
him and I said you know what I'll feel
totally successful with this if I know
that I've done everything I could
possibly do to make it as good as I
possibly can and that means never you
know being lazy and not doing another
revision or never not doing the research
or never not hiring the fact-checker
or never not testing the recipe again or
whatever and that once I know I've given
everything and like turned every stone
then I will be able to respond to any
criticism I'll be able to accept any
praise because I'll know that I did
anything right to me a big big thing
about responding to criticism is if
there's a reason I made a choice and I
can speak to that articulately then I'm
happy to accept criticism because
sometimes it's just a difference of
opinion but if I felt pressure to do
something or
I know that I didn't do my best or
whatever then a lot of times that
criticism like really sort of gets me in
the gut and and so I really did that
work and I also sort of committed to not
reading reviews you know and not reading
comments and stuff and so I've sort of
shielded myself from a lot of stuff but
I have felt to generally really safe and
and strong since the book came out and
it's nice that there's all of the sort
of praise or whatever but I also just
feel yeah I feel good about what I've
done and I know the ways I could have
done it better there's always and I get
to go do more work in the world and try
and do that better you know how did your
therapist help you or how did you put
systems in place so that that definition
of success would be at the forefront of
your mind
I I don't know of course because I don't
have telepathy but I suspect there had
to be some point where you saw maybe it
wasn't a negative review but they've
just a lukewarm response or perhaps just
some idiot on the internet with a loud
voice yelling something or other and for
at least a moment you were back in your
old mindset of looking for external
validation and in this case not finding
it I did that happen at all if so
happens all the time
yes it's how do you take that I think
very enabling definition of success and
kind of bring it onto the front lines
with you or there any exercises that you
did was it the speaking to the therapist
on a weekly basis how did how did it
because this is something I struggle
with I also have historically beaten the
hell out of myself for the the smallest
mistakes and always looked for the
things that can be improved rather than
the things that were done well so this
is also selfishly something I'd love to
I mean I feel you like it's I don't know
why I'm we're wired this way but we are
and it's its own struggle I absolutely
you know I still get those emails one
really clear example that I can think of
oh here you know what this is so epic
so I had to separate fact checkers check
my book for science for the cooking
science just because I'm not a scientist
and I'm sure I got some things wrong and
it turned out I got a bunch of things
wrong and so luckily we caught almost
all of them and in the last minute sort
of shuffle to like input all of their
changes I accidentally what's the word
when you invite I said something
positive when I should have used a
negative I inverted the thing and it
ended up being like on the very first
page of anything science related in the
book page 29 like the most basic
definition of osmosis right and I
accidentally inverted it and gave the
opposite definition which really sets me
up to look like an idiot you know for
the next 400 pages and it happened in
and I didn't realize that this had
happened until the very first the day of
publication when like the first Amazon
reviews went up and someone very kindly
mentioned it in an Amazon review and I
lost my mind I was like this is gonna
you know cuz seventy thousand books had
been printed I was like seventy thousand
people are gonna get the wrong
information and understand osmosis wrong
because of me and you know think I'm
stupid and I sort of just was like
everyone you know this is comes true
that my greatest fear that I'm not a
brilliant food science person you know
which I'm not a brilliant food science
person like all of this and so it really
sort of was and that was really hard for
me to let go of and be like well I made
a mistake it's a mistake I tried my best
and everything else there's gonna be
many more copies of this book we're
gonna fix it for the future and and so I
sort of was able to work through the
idea that I had made a mistake you know
and a mistake is totally different than
making a bad choice or I had to forgive
myself for making a mistake and
so maybe a year after that I received
this really nasty email from somebody
who took the time to you know and he was
a scientist he's a scientist and so he
took the time to write this really angry
email about this mistake and how if on
page 29 it basically like he actualized
the things that I had been so afraid of
a year before and he made it he made it
true he manifested my worst nightmare
and so he wrote me this really mean
email about how how could this have made
it to publication and what how lazy was
I and my publisher and don't we do
fact-checking and if this mistake is on
page 29 then he couldn't possibly trust
anything else I have to say and all of
this kind of stuff and by that time like
I had been so sort of I just forgiven
myself for this mistake so clearly that
I was able to write back to him and say
listen you know this was a mistake I'm
sorry for this mistake
we've remedied it since in future
printings and I really hope that the
next time you make a mistake people
treat you with more compassion than you
just treated me you know and so and then
he wrote that he actually wrote back and
he was super sorry but it was just you
know that he took it was a it came on
like the official letterhead of his
university and so that was a good
practice for me to sort of understand
the cycle of this thing you know and you
know of course I'm gonna beat myself up
but like then what do I do right after
that and so how do i reframe it and like
often what I like to do is think about
how I'd treat somebody else or how I
would talk to a friend of mine who made
a mistake such a mistake or got received
such criticism and I would always be way
nicer to anyone else so I'm trying my
hardest to treat myself like that now
too but that's easier said than done
yeah it is easier said than done but
it's it's I think it gets easier with
the addition of examples like that and
people hearing that so that they don't
feel quite as alone Abe
also be enabled in the sense because
they see that it can be improved and I
have to I have to share one one book
story because it's it's it's not
entirely dissimilar but I don't I don't
know if I've shared it before I just
feel compelled because I'm over
caffeinated which is I remember when my
first book so the 4-hour workweek it's
getting printed and I'm gonna get my
first real copy and I I come home from
lunch at one point and there's this
there's this thick yellow padded
envelope that has been shipped to my
house and on the doorstep and I pick it
up and I know it's the book and what I
said to myself it did not open it I said
to myself I know when I open this book
I'm gonna find a typo and I need to
prepare for that typo so I waited all
day until like 7 p.m. I poured a glass
of wine like sat at my kitchen table and
open this book and then right in the
[ __ ] dedication huge types like first
I'm glad I have my wine but and at that
point the same thing okay there are
however many tens of thousands of these
floating or how do people are going to
open it before they even get to my first
paragraph of prose I feel like what I
mean it still gets me I mean I read a
column for The Times magazine where you
know it goes through two editors at
least a fact-checker and a copy editor
and still mistakes get through you know
and and people really take the time to
write to me about grammatical errors and
so and so I just and it always I have a
little punch in my gut and then I'm just
like well it was a mistake you know I
I've had I'm getting better one small
way in which I'm getting better being
nicer to myself is letting go of
mistakes and it is I do think it's
really funny for people like me and you
know when we're literally faced with
them on the very first page like it's
just a good reminder you know no one's
perfect yeah
like every single time you have a piece
of writing that is important to you
there will be some error that I think
has has like a consciousness of its own
and just wills itself through all of the
copy editors to make its way into into
print but so it goes have you found any
particular I've and I'm not proud of
this but I've never gone to therapy I've
actually had a few sessions here and
there but really something like three or
four sessions over the course of my life
and it never I never took to it have you
found any particular type of therapy to
be helpful for you um I love my
therapist
it's thought he's the only one I've ever
been to I met him because he was my
friend's boyfriend's therapist so and as
and being an insane person who just like
is I'm just really highly anxious and
highly you know kind of neurotic
I googled his name a whole bunch of
times before I went to go see him and
after I started seeing him to try and
figure out as much information about him
and the kind of therapy that he
practices as possible
he's definitely old to go therapists
there's no information on the internet
about him so I actually don't even
really know I've asked him so many times
and he's really evasive about the
specific kinds of things because he
incorporates I think so many different
types of methods into his work and even
in we've been together I think almost
almost maybe not quite ten years yet but
he's changed a lot I can tell that he's
going out and learning and the things
that he focuses on change a lot so for
very frustratingly to me for a really
long time his answer to almost anything
I would say would be like and how do you
feel in your body and I was like I don't
want to talk about I feel my body and so
but it's like over many years he has
trained me to really be attuned to my
feelings in my body which I think that's
a lot of somatic work and and I think
technically what he does is
cognitive behavioral therapy and so
that's sort of the larger framework and
then within that we do a lot of
meditation and a lot of this somatic
work and I feel like for somebody like
me who is so much in my head and so much
about action it is such a nice practice
and such a great gift to myself to have
this place where I go once a week where
I am just led back into my body and into
my feelings and have trained myself to
really be aware of my feelings and not
just my thoughts I think for yeah I and
and so I'm so grateful to him and to
this work for that this this is
something that's top of mind for me
because a friend of mine just came back
I want to say about a month ago from a
Goenka Vipassana meditation retreat and
it I've never gone to a going of
meditation retreat but it seemed at
least in his experience to focus almost
if not completely exclusively on bodily
sensations you're not following your
thoughts you're always returning to
focusing on these different bodily
sensations and I'd love to hear if
you're willing because I do think this
is very important for me and and
potentially for a lot of people
listening how this the somatic awareness
this reconnecting to the body and the
feelings ends up translating to your
life right so whether it's whether it's
could you give an example situation so
well and this Tim is so crazy because
this is not that different of a
conversation than where we started with
the manifestation Journal to be honest
so I have always been a really like gut
led person you know intuitive person and
especially in my career like where I'm
I'm making decisions about well it
doesn't feel right to go work for this
or doesn't feel right to accept
that job and so and anytime I've
regretted doing something or I've gotten
myself into some complicated
professional pickle or a personal pickle
it's often because I ignored that gut
feeling that got voice and so what this
work teaches me to do is I'm basically
just strengthening the muscle of that
gut feeling you know and sometimes it's
not just my gut it's sometimes my heart
feeling but I'm teaching myself to
listen to the really like quiet
everything else really as much as
possible quiet my mind and all the
things telling me well you should do
this or there was this much money or
shouldn't you do this thing because then
you would get to be on a you know
billboard with so-and-so or whatever you
know all these other reasons it sort of
gets rid of the reasoning and it helps
me listen to my heart and my gut so let
me think of an example that recently
happened well here here's a here's and
you could some you could disguise
details to protect no no I mean there
are I'm just there like I have a friend
who recently so I have been I've been in
a lot of emotional pain for the last
several months I've been in them really
sort of just like feeling the weight of
the world I have been learning a lot of
things about my own life and things that
I feel responsible for in terms of ways
that I've participated in in sort of I
don't know systems that have put me down
you know as like a immigrant kid with a
funny name and sort of I had made
decisions to maybe if I just achieve
enough that people won't notice that I'm
different and then they'll accept me
there's been a lot of that in my life of
like let me infiltrate this elite
institution and make my way to the top
and then there will be no way that
anyone can deny that I belong here so
that sort of been looking back at my
life that's been the pattern of
everything that I've done and I am sort
of reckoning with what that's meant for
me and how I want to
to moving forward and there there's a
lot of pain in that for me so I've been
really down and a lot of my friends can
really tell that and to the point where
a lot of them started checking in on me
like via the phone via text via email
and I didn't know why a lot of people
were checking in on me so because I just
have been in such sort of rage and pain
and I have had this Boulder of anger and
sadness and and hurt in my chest and
about a month ago I went to go talk to a
friend who reached out to me and she
said please come talk to me like I want
to talk to you about this I'm worried
about you I'm worried that you don't
have the kind of supportive you know
deeply mutually supportive relationships
in your life that will support you
through this and also through all of the
stuff that's coming your way with this
show coming out and all this kind of
stuff so I went there and I thought she
was gonna give me a hug and tell me how
much she loves me and tell me how great
I am and I deserve all this great
friendship or whatever and she actually
sat me down and she said you know these
are these ways in which you've been
letting down me you've been letting down
the people around you and I know that
you're in pain because you feel really
lonely and separate from us but you're
actually doing it to yourself and and so
if you can work on some of this stuff I
think it will not only improve your
relationships but you'll feel better and
I mean I was not it was a real intense
come-to-jesus we were standing on the
side of the lake on the corner of the
street in San Francisco and crying we
were both crying for like two hours it
was really intense and I did not expect
it at all and you know and she said all
this stuff and my immediate reaction was
to be really defensive and then as soon
as I started to form the defensive
sentences and but this but that I
realized like well it doesn't even
matter because her experience of me
isn't has nothing to do with my reasons
for why I have not been there for her in
this way or that way so I just sort of
like deflated and I looked at her and I
said well what do I do
like how do I be better for us for you
for me for our friends and so she told
me and she said later she said I can't
believe you didn't even have a single
defensive reaction
like it was I was really prepared for
that and it was really amazing that you
did it so we had this very intense sort
of three hours together where we
unpacked all of this stuff and I asked
her what I could do she gave me a whole
list of basic ways in which I could be a
better friend and um and ultimately I
felt very loved because I think it's
really hard to tell somebody you know
those heart have those hard talks so I
felt really loved and cared for by the
fact that she took the time and the
energy and set the intention of setting
me straight in these things and as I was
driving home I got back into my car and
I had this ice i sat and I buckled the
safe I think when I buckled the safety
belt and it went across my chest I
realized that this pain that this
Boulder of pain that has been in my
chest probably at least since December
you know six or seven or eight months
was gone and it wasn't that I felt so
great all of a sudden but this rock that
has been weighing down every breath was
no longer there and I it sort of maybe
had been broken up and dispersed into my
body and I and I woke up the next
morning and I cried I mean I was still
really upset about get receiving this
sort of very difficult feedback but I
also felt realized I felt really
empowered because she you know so much
of my pain has been about a feeling of
powerlessness a feeling that like there
are so many things going on in the world
that I have no power to change or
improve and this she gave me something I
could do something about and not only
could I do something about it
but I could make my life better and my
friends lives better in the process and
so I think having power and feeling
feeling feeling the you know very strong
and pure love of my friend really helped
to dissolve this bad feeling and this is
not to say like my depression
has lifted I suddenly feel so much
better but I will say there was a market
difference a market immediate difference
and everyone who I am around is like wow
you're so much lighter and I really do
feel a lot lighter so I don't know if
that was really clear for you it's it's
I think this is important territory to
explore so I appreciate you being game
and we will we will probably come back
to some of this but I don't want I want
to make sure that we explore the the
entire map of the terrain up and down
and you mentioned you mentioned love a
few times so I thought perhaps if you'd
be willing to share if you could answer
the question when did you first fall in
love with food I mean was there any
particular moment any particular meal
where it just really kind of grabbed you
by the collar and and it made you become
as involved or excited about food as you
are today oh wow I don't know you know I
don't know because my mom is such an
incredible cook and it was cooking for
us and shopping for us and spending time
on food was the primary way that my mom
really showed us her love I think I've
always associated cooking and eating
with that feeling of like maternal
warmth you know and it's what I try to
put out into the world there was there's
I don't remember eating this but the
stories up I have so many pictures of
myself as a little kid and the stories
also for me now as a cook there's so
many things that I understand about the
length that my mom went to to make this
really delicious and nutritious and
culturally meaningful food for us every
day and how much work went into that how
much time and labor and so there's a lot
of things that in retrospect I I have so
much appreciation for her about that I
probably just couldn't have ever
imagined
but there's this dish that she
quote-unquote invented called salmon
polo and polo just means rice and so and
it was I think the food she fed me when
I was teething you know and it was this
like mushy Rhett it was a long like
basmati rice with like really soft
pieces of potato and tomato and chicken
and so it was just all these like you
know typical kid foods but really really
soft so that you could eat them even if
you didn't have teeth and and and I
would eat that with yogurt and I loved
it so much and I loved that there was a
dish named after me you know and and I
still sometimes go make that for myself
like so to me I think the salmon
polarizer is a great example of that and
it's funny because there have been for
sure some really meaningful meals that
I've had and there's the one that sort
of led me to become a cook that has was
I think really important in the story
and in the timeline but very rarely is
is a meal for me about the food it's
almost always about what happens at the
table you know in the conversations and
the feelings and all that kind of stuff
so I think yeah for me like yeah it's
maybe also not the healthiest thing to
associate foods so deeply with love if
you were well let me just ask the
question where did you grow up I grew up
in San Diego I was born there my parents
came from Iran in the mid 70s to San
Diego and then I was born in 79 and I
lived this really funny you know in
retrospect this really funny life where
I was art my high school was two blocks
from the beach I grew up going to the
beach all the time I eaten fish tacos
you know hanging driving around in cars
with all my like very American friends
and then I would come home and my mom
always said when you come back home this
is Iran and so at home we spoke Farsi
either a Persian rugs every
a Persian food you know she insisted
that we like follow the traditions of
the culture and respect our elders and
so I had this these two worlds that I
was very aware of and and still sort of
look back and think think a lot about
and and think a lot about how that's
defined me and I think it led to me
feeling like an outsider no matter where
I was because I'd never quite belonged
and I in a way I think that feeling of
never quite belonging has come into is
one of my superpowers because I it's
very easy for me even as I become more
like quote-unquote popular or successful
or whatever to imagine what it's like to
be on the outside and so it really has
made inclusivity and inclusion be a
fundamental part of all of my work and
so whether I'm writing a recipe for the
New York Times magazine and I constantly
put myself into the shoes of someone who
doesn't live in California and have
access to the world's best produce you
know or what ingredients can anyone buy
any grocery store or will these
instructions make sense to anyone or am
i using language that will make you feel
like you don't belong here
or or or whatever so to me it's it's
this funny thing where these things that
caused me so much sort of pain and
confusion as a kid have ended up being
really wonderful tools in my work I'm so
glad you're you're talking about not
fitting in being a gift and it's just
it's so timely and I feel like we we
should we should definitely hug it out
at some point but literally just a week
ago I was reflecting on how many of the
things that I've viewed from my past as
having damaged me or resulting in me
being damaged have actually been gifts
and and one of them was always feeling
in a sense that I didn't fit in and
being an observer right because at least
I don't know
what your experience was like but I very
often ended up standing in a room and
feeling like I wasn't actually there but
I was like a camera on the wall
observing what was happening and what I
noticed for instance in your writing and
I I've read a million cookbooks excited
I certainly would not consider myself a
real chef as you are but have read a lot
I keep very few in my actual kitchen and
your book is one of those books because
you are so good at putting on the lens
of beginner's mind and really putting
yourself in the place of whoever it is
you are writing for whose intended to
receive the teaching that you are
putting down on paper or on the screen
so I wanted to dig into that a little
bit because I feel that that reframe is
so powerful and it's easy to forget too
it's easy to forget to put those glasses
on with that reframe for sure but
tonight I have I definitely have a
response to your question but also you
said something so beautiful and so crazy
that that I feel like I needed to read
you this quote that I just saw on
instant it was by Marco Pierre White I
dunno who knows yeah that's what is it
wet white heat or white hot was the book
yeah he was this like kind of sorry
Marco Pierre White he he I don't even
know how to describe him he was a
trend-setting avant-garde chef in London
in the 80s and 90s he was kind of the
original bad boy if you will like a
proto Anthony Bourdain in some way is
just like known for his aggressiveness
and and his sort of brilliance and his
creativity and I think he's just sort of
this like tortured bad-boy kind of guy
and so there's this beautiful picture I
saw of him on on this account called
niche on Instagram
and this quote from him so he wrote I
believe there's really two species of
human beings the first species is the
most common there's more of them there
are individuals who like we all are born
into a certain world and they become a
product of that world
they absorb that environment they're
born into they become an extension of it
they become part of it
the rarer species in my opinion is the
individual who has been damaged as a
child they have suffered misfortune and
great tragedy this doesn't mean that
there are better people
it just means they've suffered and very
few individuals suffer that tragedy but
what happens is an invisible shell
covers you it protects you so you don't
absorb the world you're brought into you
don't become part of that world you
observe that world it was like exactly
what you just know and so it was really
I mean and I don't know that my life has
been so dramatic to have been filled
with like that level of tragedy but
absolutely I think human small pains and
small traumas you know or whatever just
like the circumstances of our lives you
know can make us feel and also the whole
idea of being an outsider lately I've
been thinking I'm like oh yeah I've
always felt on the outside but I'm like
does anyone really feel in terms of the
beginner's mind and that you know that
work I think I have to there are two
sort of parts to that for me I think
when I started teaching people how to
cook like I never forgot what it's what
it felt like to be 19 years old in a
world-class kitchen and not know
anything I didn't know the difference
between parsley and celery so or parsley
and cilantro I did know parsley and
celery but but you know I I didn't know
anything I didn't know any fancy terms I
didn't know even the most basic things
everything just was sort of overwhelming
and too much information and so I've
never forgotten the feeling of being so
overwhelmed and lost and having nothing
to cling to and I feel like as long as I
can remember that and return to that
every time
I I go to teach or talk or write that
then I'm really serving the people that
I'm trying to serve which who are the
people who don't know you know there are
so many times where I had to reset
myself and remember I wasn't writing my
book or doing my work to impress my
peers you know it's not for them you
know it's not you know also like their
way there are million better chefs out
there than than me and I'm not out there
to compete with them I'm there to sort
of be a translator from the professional
you know for the amateur from the
professional kitchen so if I can
remember that and and remember the
feeling of being the beginner then I can
do my job right and as a writer this the
way the I would say the person who
really has served as a model for me in
that more than anyone else is Michael
Pollan
oh yeah and we're gonna and we're
definitely gonna definitely gonna dig
into him right after he recorded with
you and he he had such a great great he
just I think like you blew his mind but
the feeling is mutual I don't know how
that guy speaks and finished prose but I
just maybe I'll figure it out one day
but he he really taught me you know and
this wasn't something he actively taught
me I learned by reading his work and
really sitting with what it was that was
so moving and effective about the way
that he writes and it's that he is not
it's an old-time time-worn journalistic
tool to put yourself in you know to go
do the experiential journalism he just
has this incredible way of immersing
himself in really complicated worlds and
being able to articulate them the war
like what he's experiencing and what
he's learning in a way for anybody and
so you know he did that with really
complicated things about GMO corn he did
that with the botanical world he has
done that with the architectural world
and you know most recently he's done it
in the psychedelic world and so when I
first sat down to
eight I was like okay I'm gonna do this
the Michael Pollan way and I tried to do
what he would do which was to be this
guide you know this newbie guide but I
realized that wasn't who I was you know
what I needed to do was establish some
authority as a teacher so I couldn't
take you on this journey with me
you know he's he's so good at doing it
in a way where he's not condescending at
all and he's but yet he's so informative
and so I really had to sort of sit with
that and let it distill through my bones
and through my mind and figure out how
can I take that kernel of not being
condescending of being really clear and
articulate of holding your hand and
bringing you through here yet also
having some authority and so the best
way that I found to do that was to do
what I did when I teach people how to
cook and when I talk to them which is to
tell the stories of when I didn't know
anything and all of the 9,000 times I've
messed everything up because that is the
closest that I can be to being in your
shoes as a person who maybe doesn't know
how to deep-fry you know or is afraid
you're gonna burn your house down or
whatever so so ultimately I couldn't be
Michael Pollan and that's fine for both
of us but but I could learn from him and
and really sort of put put some of his
techniques into action and we are going
to revisit that because I'm fascinated
by writing process which really for
people read for people reading if you're
reading then this then I want to figure
out how you're achieving synesthesia but
the people listening to this writing
process you can just substitute creative
process it's same same I mean the same
with experimenting in the kitchen same
with you name it completely new music
but you had mentioned age 19 and I this
might be a good segue to the question
how did you first get exposed to Alice
Waters so the very first time I ever
heard of Alice Waters was when I moved
to Berkeley in 1997 to attend college
and at my freshman orientation somebody
was like oh and there's a famous
restaurant with the famous chef in town
and to me coming from San Diego eating
mostly home-cooked food and sometimes
fish tacos and you know Mexican food and
Chinese food or whatever there was no I
had no concept of what a fancy
restaurant or a famous chef was so that
sort of went in one ear and out the
other and then the following year I fell
in love and my boyfriend was from San
Francisco and we spent all of our time
like all of our free time eating so he
took me you know to his favorite
ice-cream place and his favorite pizza
place and all the sort of childhood
places and he had always wanted to go to
Chez Panisse and so I still didn't
really know what it was and I but we
decided to save weed I knew it was
expensive so we saved two hundred and
twenty dollars over the course of seven
months and we there's a whole thing
where it you have to reserve your table
at Chez Panisse a month in advance but
the menu which is fixed only is
published a week in advance and so I was
not yet a really adventurous eater you
know I had the definitely things so we
did this complicated thing where we
reserved for like four nights in a row
and then when the menu was published we
chose the one we wanted and canceled all
the other ones because the menu is
different each day you know and so then
we so then we went in and I was yeah I
was 19 I was wearing like black tank top
and denim skirt we were very out of
place and this very probably Berkeley's
fanciest restaurant
I think everyone probably knew that we
were not regulars and and we had this
really special meal and I grew up eating
really delicious food so it wasn't that
this food was like the most amazing
thing I'd ever eaten it was just the
entire experience was unlike any I had
ever had in a restaurant I really felt
like I was at somebody's house and they
were caring for me and they were so
attentive to everything you know the
bread and butter was never empty the
water was never empty like the the plate
the second we were done was whisked away
there was just the sort of attention
that I had never received in a
restaurant before and I think that
really got me and so when the dessert
came it was a chocolate souffle
and I the server asked if I had ever had
souffle before and I said no and she
said would you like me to show you how
to eat it and so she said well you poke
a hole with your spoon in the top and
then you pour this like raspberry sauce
in and that way every bite has sauce so
I did that and I took a bite and she
said how is it and I said oh it's really
good but it would be a lot better if I
had a glass of cold milk and I had no
idea that it was like so rude to tell
this person it was a fancy restaurant
what would make my thing better you know
like and also I had no idea that in
fancy you know dining fine dining it's
considered like a total faux pas to
drink milk after 10:00 a.m. that's why
in Italy if you order a cappuccino after
10:00 a.m. they know you're American
because only babies drink milk after 10
a.m.
Wow I had no idea this is good Daniela
alright so like even having like the
idea of like asking for milk with
chocolate after dinner is like so gross
to me you know to people in fancy food
and so she kind of laughed she was like
you want milk and I was like yeah like
hello hot chocolate thing cold milk like
good combo and so she went and she
brought me milk and then she also
brought us each a glass of desert wine
to sort of teach us the refined
accompaniment and there was this really
sweet gesture if you get what you've
enjoyed your cold milk yeah you may want
to sample another option it was really I
don't know it was like a little
education and so I was so moved by this
whole experience and this whole dinner
that I wrote this letter to Alice Waters
and I said oh you know I brought it in a
few months later asking for a job as a
busser and so I always had sort of like
a basic job that I worked throughout
college so I brought it in and they said
oh you have to bring that to the floor
manager so they led me to the floor
manager's office and when she opened the
door it was the souffle lady and so so
I remembered me I think I you know in
retrospect I think she was probably
really desperate cuz she was like you
want to start tomorrow
so I started I started the next day and
pretty immediately I was just so
enchanted by what was happening in the
kitchen and that I just I wanted to
learn I wanted to learn what those
people knew I mean that restaurant
really exists like a pyramid and the
cooks are at the top they're the most
respected most skilled people who worked
there and I wanted to I wanted that you
know I was so attracted to that what
what did the letter say that you wrote
to me do you remember any of it because
you have your letter thing as far as I
can tell in the homework that I've done
yes but do you recall any of the
elements of that letter sure I used the
word magical it's a very severe II like
simian word is I'm like I had a magical
dinner at your magical restaurant and I
was so you know inspired and I also
don't think Alice Waters ever saw that
letter I think it like stopped with the
floor manager probably but I had never
worked in a restaurant I'm sure I
revealed that that I was just so moved
by this incredible dinner that I wanted
to work there and could I please have an
opportunity I think it was a pretty
straightforward one I'm pretty good with
like the flattery I would say that's
like an important part of these letters
but in my life where I've like you know
I'm writing to someone because I'm a
huge fan and and I'm like looking to
collaborate or for some opportunity so I
start like really with like laying it on
thick you know and then I mean it's
genuine but like and then and then I do
my big ask and so yeah I had Dallas
waters letter then years later I had the
Michael Pollan letter let's pause on the
Michael Pollan this this is place a
place s there's time in place when you
get a letter to Michael Pollan Oh
and when when's the letter to Michael
Pollan so yeah where were you what were
you doing oh so that was you about ten
years later yeah almost ten years later
I was working at a different restaurant
in Berkeley and I saw Michael Pollan's
and
in the reservation book and I was a huge
fan of his and I'd met him a couple
times at Chez Panisse and he was he you
know he'd been involved with Alice and
and her work like their work really sort
of intersected and so they were big
supporters of one another and I remember
you know before botany of desire came
out that like for whatever reason we had
a copy of a galley at Chez Panisse that
we were passing around and eat and
reading and I was like who is this
person this is amazing and so since I
had read that book I had been a
voracious reader of anything that he
wrote and I really admired the way that
he was an advocate and so eloquent about
the things that I care so deeply about
and and work on and and so to me he was
somebody who I really looked up to also
because even though I began cooking I
never let go of the idea of wanting to
be a writer like I always wanted to be a
writer since way before I was a cook and
that was something that I really kept
pursuing in small ways even as I was
cooking and so by the time that Michael
Pollan the name appeared in our
reservation book I had applied to a few
different creative writing programs and
gotten in and deferred and never taken a
leap and I knew that he was teaching at
the UC Berkeley School of Journalism so
I wrote this I like quickly scroll doubt
this card saying you know I'm your
number one fan you mean so much to me I
would love to come out at one of your
classes and you know basically that it
wasn't even a super big letter but then
I gave it to the servers and I went home
that night and I asked them to give it
to him when he was eating so then you
know they did and then a few weeks later
I mean this speaks so like directly to
who Michael is he wrote me back he wrote
me an email and said why don't you come
in and talk to me and so he wrote me
back I went in to go talk to him and I
asked him to audit his class and he said
you know it might be a little bit tricky
because a lot of people want to audit
the class and and and and so he's like
but there's one spot there's one extra
spot so why don't you come on the first
day and we'll
you know you guys can all vie for that
spot so I showed up the first day of
this tiny class there was like 11 people
in the class I think and I think over
200 people showed up for that last spot
and so and so we each had to write an
index card saying why we what you know
why we wanted to audit so we did and
then we went away and I later that day I
was lamenting to my friend that there
was no way that I would ever get the
spot and my friend said don't you know
anything don't you know anything about
academics and I was like I don't I don't
tell me she said you need to write him
right now and say that he needs to give
you this precisely because you are a
cook
and you will bring a different you know
you will bring a different viewpoint
into this class and the conversations
will be different because you're from
the inside of this world because the
class was about it's called following
the food chain and it was about the food
industry and so I did that even though
it felt so wrong to write to Michael
Pollan and tell him that what he needed
to do you know of course like from you
know some 23 year old or what I don't
know I would hold I was 29 maybe but so
I did and he he was like okay like it
was so simple in here you know I asked I
did the thing that I was so scared to do
and I asked and then that led to me
auditing this class which ended up being
a really incredible and pivotal moment
for me but I don't know that I could
have put my finger on at that time but
now I look back at it and it's not only
when I got got to work with Michael and
what led to you know us working together
on writing and cooking but also I'm
became part of an incredible community
of journalists and writers and which is
a thing I had always wanted by then I
had a really vast network of cooking
people and I was part of an incredible
cooking world but I didn't have a
community at all to support me as a
writer I didn't know what a pitch was I
didn't know anything about writing I
didn't know articles are measured in
words you know I didn't know any of that
so I learned a lot of that not only from
that class but also just from being
around these people and having peers who
I could ask all these questions of and
now I worked in an office
you know shared writing space with so
many of those people I've gone on to
collaborate with them we you know
they're they're my community who I am
constantly sort of reaching out to and
now I'm able to support in my own ways
and so that was a really important thing
that I asked for let's let's look at the
nitty-gritty of that so you start with a
note in the restaurant that says I'm
your biggest fan
can I audit your class what were there
any other ingredients in that note I'm
gonna I'm gonna hit I'm gonna hit oh it
was a card so it wasn't I remember that
it was a card it was not like a letter
on paper that was a bad card like
Hallmark card we took a business card
yeah like I went to the I think cuz on
the street where that restaurant was
there was a couple stationery stores so
I think I bought a card like yeah like a
heart like some sort of greeting card so
I it wasn't so long whatever I wrote I
think I just I think really it said like
my name is sameen I'm a huge fan of
yours I have always wanted to write I
really would like to call it at your
class it would be so mean it would be it
would mean so much to me I mean there
honestly I don't know why there's no
reason why Michael Pollan not sure
you've given yourself enough credit so
that's that's that's part one part two
he he writes you back
you show up it's like the gladiatorial
games with 200 competitors and you write
in the next card do you remember any of
what you put on the index card I don't
know man I don't remember that all right
so then your friend says hey don't you
know anything about I get em X no I
don't just tell me you need to write
this and so you send this follow-up
email do you remember like subject line
anything else that you put in that email
no should I see if it's in my eye I
don't know if I had this email address
then you know we could we could look at
it we could I could look at you get
sense to be later and I can if you find
it I'll put it in the show notes for
people I
the thing for me is that I know that I'm
very verbose so any time I sit down to
ask for something I think and I
intuitively knew this before and now I
know it really clearly unarticulated to
myself and other people which is like if
you're writing an email to somebody to
ask them for something just get to it
right you know don't beat around the
bush yeah and so so I don't need your
whole backstory like I don't mean the
zoo boo boo boo boo just like say the
thing so I'm pretty sure I did that one
pretty tightly because we were already
in this conversation yeah you need to
have me in the class because I'll bring
and I have this you know and I work in
the sustainable food world and I'm gonna
bring because what he had told me I sort
of glossed over this before
but what he had told me when I had come
to his office hours before I went to
that first day of class was he said
listen I know you want to take this
class but it's never gonna happen
because I have obligations to a long
list of people and you're at the very
end of that list because first my
obligations are to the students of this
graduate school and then of the other
graduate schools of UC Berkeley and then
to the undergraduates of UC Berkeley and
then the community and so there are so
many other like paying students ahead of
you that you are low priority to me I
mean he didn't do it in a mean way but
it was just like he was telling me what
it was and so but he was like but if you
want you can come listen to this day so
I did I saw it in action the fact that
there were so many people I also think
he's a softie at heart even though he's
like comes across as a rule follower so
even though they were only supposed to
be 12 people in that class I think there
ended up being 15 of us you know and so
so but but yeah I I don't think if I had
not followed up with that email and and
said listen like you need me precisely
because I'm not one of those people
further up on this list that that was
why you know I was so enthusiastic and
in
sort of since the class like during the
class and since the class it became
really apparent that I did do it
precisely that that I did bring a
viewpoint that nobody else in that room
could have and I helped arrange for us a
field trip you know to this like
wackadoodle sustainable farm and there
were ways where because I had an
insider's perspective I could connect
other students with like the kinds of
stories that they probably wouldn't be
able to find on their own because I was
living it you know and immersed in it
mm-hmm
so I don't think regrets it I hope not
so we're talking we're talking about a
writer who's had a big influence on your
writing your career let's back step for
a second to two books that have had a
big impact on you and in the course of
doing my my homework I don't know when
this came about but and can't believe
everything you read on the Internet so
feel free to correct but a list of books
that the Chez Panisse chefs gave you
this is something that came up and then
there were there a few folks who came up
I guess Marcel has on patience gray
could you describe how that list got to
you and what were what were some of the
books on that list that had a big impact
on you for sure I mean those are also
just cookbooks so I have other other
books I can talk about too if you want
but both let's let's do both and you can
do that in whatever order you like yeah
but in terms of the cookbooks that have
been deeply formative I think I don't
before so one of the incredible things
about Chez Panisse is that and this is
absolutely comes from Alice and the and
the world that she's created is she is
an artist above all else and so she
really surrounds herself with deeply
creative people an artists of all
different kinds and so food is just one
part of this lifestyle that she really
tries to create and teach people and
immerse people in and so beautiful
writing is a big part of that and I
think I had a pretty limited exposure to
cookbooks before I came to Chez Panisse
I just knew them as the thing that you
look up the recipe in to make for dinner
and so when I begged the chef's there to
teach me how to cook you know and just
to like set the scene the time was about
I think this was 2000 the restaurant
kept winning you know best restaurant in
America from Gourmet magazine which at
the time was like the biggest sort of
award of its type and so it really if
there there was no reason for these
chefs to let me into the kitchen there
was a line a mile long of much more
experienced people than me trying to get
this job and I knew that and they knew
that everyone knew that and so I knew
nothing and I all I had was my
enthusiasm really and my dedication and
like my work ethic so I asked the chef's
what I needed to do in order to earn an
unpaid apprenticeship like that's what I
was competing for and they said you need
to cook every day you need to watch
these cooks every day you're here you
need to learn how to taste and develop
your palate and you need to go home and
read all these books and they gave me a
stack of like probably 30 books I mean
they didn't actually give me the books
they told me about 30 bucks to read and
so they're like these are the books that
are the Chez Panisse Canon and things
like they were book they were books
unlike anything I had ever seen so
patients gray who was an incredible
incredible writer in the mid century who
travelled with her husband throughout
like Turkey and Greece and Italy and
Spain wrote this beautiful book called
honey from a weed that is just it's like
a poem and yes there are recipes with
like cups and measures in there but
there is just a way that sort of one
country to the next she connects all
these dots and it's so beautiful and
moving and it's it's it put together
writing and food in a way unlike I had
ever seen before and so that was a
really really formative book for me
there was another one kind of in the
same vein called the auberge of the
flowering hearth by a person named roy
andrews de Groote
I think it's his pen name and this this
one was a like if a novel met a cookbook
kind of because it was an imaginary
world but this guy had sort of created
about this like magical auberge
somewhere in the mountains bears which
is like bear it like a like a mountain
hotels or in France yeah and so and a
mountain in a country in I guess my god
you know and so there were just these
kind of like beautiful narratives that
were intertwined in talking about food
that were so moving to me and then there
were the basic cookbooks that I had to
learn you know history and tradition and
culture from things like Richard Olney's
writing and yeah Martella has on and oh
gosh I mean all of the Chez Panisse
books so it was really a kind of a world
that I had never been exposed to because
we my house had growing up we had two
Persian cookbooks our culinary tradition
was entirely oral and then we had like a
Sesame Street cookbook that had a banana
bread recipe that I used to make when I
was little and that was about it there
was not this like deep tradition of
cookbooks that I grew up around so this
was a really moving an influential thing
for me and then um yeah writing wise I
have read mean so many I read so much
nonfiction I mean I love love love John
McPhee I love yeah I mean to me I've
learned so much about structure from
John McPhee so do you have a favorite
one or two favorites recommend to all to
all people if you read the description
people really like what an entire book
on a single tennis match trust me yeah
and trust you and it really taught me
that you know there was a period where I
was like maybe I write my book like the
levels of the game and I find a way to
tell a story you know there's just he is
a master of structure and I find you
know I for me a challenge as a writer
and also as now just like a creative
thinker
one of the most thrilling things for me
that I'm so excited by but also too
intimidated by is coming up with
structure for things and so and and in
being in search of always like the
simplest most elegant structure and I
feel like you can convey information so
much more clearly when a structure is
right and and simple you know and so
it's fun it's a fun practice right now
I'm figuring out like if I'm gonna do
another show and I've and or another
book and I think I figure it out an idea
and so now I'm just like okay how do i
structure it so it's just that kind of
stuff where I love I love those and very
randomly this book I saw one day at a
store when I was struggling like on the
900th the draft of my own book and it
has been so meaningful and moving to me
it's called several short sentences on
writing and it's by a writer named
veralyn klinken Berg who teaches at Yale
and he used to have a column in The New
York Times I think it was called like on
rural living where and he's written
about writing and the entire point of
this whole small book is make your
sentences shorter and it really is so
good with what is to look at your bio
it's a very impressive bio right being
called the next Julia Child by NPR's all
things considered your New York Times
bestselling author you have this TV show
you have all these various accolades and
I think it's easy for someone perhaps to
look at that be very intimidated and
assume that you've just been getting up
at bat and hitting home runs since since
since you began one after the other so
if you'd be open to it I'd love to talk
about failures whether those are
failures apparent failures that set you
up for later success and of course those
people who've read trust mentors will
recognize this question or heard the
podcast I like to ask this question in
terms of like favorite failures past
failures that really taught you
something that seemed like a failure but
in fact if they hadn't happened
something else which was a success
wouldn't have happened later can you
give us any examples that there's so
many options here yeah I mean I was just
I was thinking you know that I came
really close to writing to to co-writing
two other books before I ended up
writing my own book and though neither
of those felt right but I was just so
desperate to work on a book that I
almost did those ones and I kind of
messed up both of those opportunities
and I felt really bad like I would never
get an opportunity to write my own book
and if I had done those I don't think
how did you mess them up if you don't
let me ask um well the one that I can
remember more clearly was it was going
to be a book about piccoli it was gonna
be a book about pickling and I was gonna
do it with a friend and there was a way
where I we met with this agent a book
literary agent who had brought the idea
to her and something I just didn't love
I don't know I couldn't have put my
finger on it but to me at that time I
was like an agent like that's a
high-powered you know what I mean only
fancy people have agents and so I felt
like I needed to prove myself to this
agent and there was something about like
our relationship just didn't feel right
and I don't know that I don't think I
trusted her completely and I felt really
kind of put down by her it just didn't
feel very good and so I think I can't
write this was so long ago I can't
remember exactly what happened but I
think I like in elegantly extracted
myself from that like I had committed to
it and then I uncommitted because I just
didn't feel like it was the right thing
and then I just worried like oh no does
this mean I'll never find an agent or
I'll never get to do a book so that was
one I'm trying to remember and then then
oh there was actually another another
agent
man I haven't like really have like a
trail of Burnt agents behind me there
was another agent who came to me and
and again she made me feel like I needed
to prove myself to her and that my ideas
weren't that good and I had this one
idea and she didn't want me to do that
and I want to find you she found me I
used to do these dinners at Tartine
bakery in San Francisco which is its own
cult play-doh and because of that these
dinners that I had it was called Tartine
After Hours became like this other it
became a little cult thing and so in a
very small world it was a very popular
thing and so I think she sort of was in
that world and so she found me through
that and there was just a way I think
what it was was I yeah I've never
actually spent the time to think about
it but in both of those situations the
relationships the fundamental primary
relationship which at that time was with
the agent like it wasn't so much with an
editor yet or anything it just was so on
uneven ground and it was this thing
where I was struggling to prove myself
as a creative thinker to them and it was
just I didn't very much feel supported
and that is not a great place for me or
maybe for anyone from which to do your
best creative work I've learned that for
sure in my career now as a writer who's
worked with so many different kinds of
editors like my current editing
situation at the Times Magazine is so
wonderful because my editor I love her
so much
and she knows exactly how to lay it to
me like she tells it to me straight you
know she knows how to give me a
smackdown when I need it but she also is
so kind and supportive and so there's
just this very fundamental trust that we
have where I used to turn stuff in to
her every every month and I call him and
I would have like a one-page apology
that I would write this like apology
email before it with with each draft and
she was like you have to stop sending
these apologies this is insane like
you're doing your best I know you're
doing your best I also know you're not
going to phone it in and also the stuff
you're turning in is not that so stop
Apollo
so but I had sort of um there's just
been all so many different experiences
I've had where where I have been made to
feel like I'm dumb or I'm not trying
hard enough and I actually I'm trying so
hard you know and so I now have learned
from my own self that I I need to be
smarter and very careful about what kind
of creative collaborations I enter
because I need a kind of a relationship
that's vulnerable and open and it's not
that I don't want criticism I actually
do want your criticism because I do want
to make it better but how do you convey
that to me you know and also do we have
a fundamental trust between the two of
us that we're both you know that we both
have are aiming toward the same goal of
you know making the best possible thing
so I think I don't know I sorry I've
completely veered away from you know
I'll be I'll be there I'll be the guide
rails it's okay because I want to I want
to actually hone in on something that
you said about your editor at The Times
who can deliver the Smackdown but do so
with a delivery that you find very
palatable now you do want the criticism
but it's a it's a question of it being
constructive and delivered in the right
way can you give any examples of how
that editor might deliver criticism or
it could be a hypothetical made-up
example or just what makes it so wok
that you know thread the needle of being
both effective criticism but but not
making you defensive or deflating you
yeah I wish I had a very specific
example but I can set the emotional tone
of it which is that there is we have
developed I mean it's been over a year
now that were in constant contact so we
have at this point developed an
understanding that I know that she wants
the best for me and she knows that I'm
always going to do my best
and so if she tells me something even in
shorthand sometimes now she does this
thing where she just writes do better
and so now I know okay like that's a
phrase that I need to do better you know
or it's not working
I think so much of it is an emotion as
like a fundamental um the emotional work
that we had done earlier and that had
come through these vulnerable exchanges
where I where I had said to her I'm
really sorry and she said listen I know
you're doing your best so once I was
able to trust her in that way
I think I have I've let go of a lot of
the defensive anis I'm trying to think
of some of the earth she was a lot more
gentle in the beginning and I think that
a lot to do with it she was very gentle
and she would she would sort of write
out more complete sentences about why
something was over explained Eeyore or
maybe like to - I know
snobby or whatever she so I think she
really did the work initially to allow
me to trust her and feel safe with her
and then that now we have such a nice
shorthand where like I can just be like
can you just do this you know or
whatever yeah I'll keep it short and
sweet
before it before you came to writing
though if we've talked about the the
co-writing
opportunities which did not manifest or
that you extricate yourself from then
ultimately having the opportunity to do
to write the type of book that you want
to write it do you have any failures or
missteps from what preceded that I
assume
yeah like the indie from the culinary
world or a restaurant world or otherwise
yes so many I mean I would say the two
biggest failures of my career are
culinary and they they sit in beautiful
contrast to one another so one of them
was I helped run a restaurant for five
years that was struggling financially
the whole time it existed and there was
a way where it was not my restaurant I
was helping my mentor run it I felt very
loyal to him and in the beginning I had
you know like restaurants are often lose
money for up to five years you know
before they sort of hit its it's really
just a terrible financial so there's a
way where like they they often lose
money for a long time before they sort
of hit steady ground and we actually hit
steady ground after three years but then
in 2008 the economy crashed and so it
was sort of just this thing where we
weren't going
we knew we were never gonna make it okay
and there were a lot of sort of I think
community there was a culture issue in
that restaurant that now with so many
years of distance I can see was almost
insurmountable and and if a culture in a
place isn't sort of support it's really
hard to turn the culture of a place
around I think and so in some ways to me
I was ready to like cut it call it quits
after three years but for my mentor this
was like his big shot that his career
had been working you know aiming toward
and he wasn't ready to give up so I I
stayed for two years longer than I
wanted to and I was really unhappy I was
really unhealthy like just physically it
really um I feel like it took a toll on
my adrenal system I had a really bad
temper this was bright you know right
but this was eventually like led to the
breakdown that led me going to therapy
like I was emotionally just out of touch
I was not that kind to the people who
worked for me it was not great it was
not my greatest hour and so I think
staying through something and feeling
how bad that made me feel how bad it
made other people feel and that it
ultimately sort of fizzled to this slow
painful death really taught me that I
don't ever want to be part of that kind
of situation again like I want to be the
one calling calling quits you know I
want to be the one who like determines
the end of a story and when I think
about it you know in any creative
project which even or business probably
in some ways a business is not so
different from a creative project like
things have a beginning a middle and an
end you know like even when people sit
down to write a movie or to write a
series even if you want to pitch a TV
series you know an ideal lifespan for a
TV series is five to seven years and so
before you even start you know how the
series is gonna end right like there's a
way where it's not a bad idea an ending
is not necessarily a failure and so I
really got to put that into practice a
couple years later when after the
restaurant closed I started this like
kind of small food market that
immediately became
a huge success and got so much media
attention and all of a sudden was um I
started it because I just missed cooking
for people and I wanted to cook a little
bit in my spare time while I was
figuring out how to be a writer and then
all of a sudden all of my time and
resources and energy were going toward
running this food market that wasn't
even the main thing I wanted to
accomplish in my life and so even as it
grew and we got more followers and more
customers and we're making more money or
whatever I knew that it wasn't what I
wanted to do so instead of letting that
also fizzle out I ended it after two
years and people really wanted like all
the food media was like what's the
gossip why is this closing I was like
it's not closing you know nothing's
wrong like I'm just closing it because I
want to do something else and so was
that was that an easy decision a hard
decision and we walk us through I don't
know though like the weeks before making
it official this is a month okay yeah so
months so I knew in in one way it was an
easy decision because my gut told me
today that I didn't want to do it in
practical terms it was much more
difficult because there were a lot of
people who I felt responsible too who
relied on this market for their income
and so and or they thought they relied
on the market for their income and so
there was a story that we all were
telling about how important this market
was in all of these people's lives and I
feel I have very maternal instincts like
I feel a lot of responsibility for the
community that I create and and to them
and so if anything I wanted I felt a
need to stay for them rather than for
myself and um and that was really brutal
and around this time I was like really
into yoga like super into yoga and and
when you go to yoga class like often
what they talk about is setting an
intention and so I was really like doing
a lot of yoga talk and uh and I had this
thing where I realized that because my
career was so amorphous because there
wasn't some like other person on whose
career I was modeling my own there
wasn't an easy way for me
know that I was moving I don't know in
the right direction toward anything I
wanted to actually accomplish right
there weren't like these landmarks of
like when you want to be a doctor you do
this this and this and this when you
want to be a lawyer you do this this and
this and so I didn't have that so how
did I know I was on the right track
to where I wanted to go and I really
started to hone this thing for myself
which was well since I don't know where
my ultimate ending point is or my
ultimate goal is I what I do know is
that it's a feeling I have a feeling in
my belly like that I I want to work
toward and so and that and that when an
opportunity comes to me or a
professional decision comes to me I can
think about in terms of if I say yes or
no to this thing will it take me closer
to or farther away from this feeling
that I tried to feel and also create in
the world and so probably the like
biggest conflict in deciding to close
that market was that that feeling has a
lot to do with community and supporting
people and I knew that closing closing
the market would sort of temp in the
short term maybe like take me farther
away from that but I also had to
fundamentally believe that it would give
me the space to like in a different way
on a larger scale go back toward that so
a few questions relate to that
why was the food market so quickly
popular and were there any particular
reasons that they come to mind I think
part of it was timing of it um so what
it was was I was really good at making
pasta that's like I lived in Italy for
two years I made pasta everyday for 10
years I really loved making pasta and
and so people when the restaurant closed
I would sort of bump into people in town
and they'd be like well we really miss
your pasta and so and I really enjoy the
like beautiful sort of manual labor of
making it and the folding and the
cutting and the whole thing and so I
thought well what if I cut out all of
the parts of having a restaurant that I
hate and I just make the pasta and sell
it to people so we had I had these
friends who had a
commercial kitchen that was empty a lot
of evenings so they let me use it and I
was like okay well how do I sell this
pasta to people so this was I think it
was 2009 so it was before I think it was
before Instagram or certainly before
Instagram was really big and I maybe had
a Twitter with like 5 followers but like
really Facebook was the main thing that
I used and so I think I put on Facebook
like I'm gonna sell some pasta does
anyone buy it and I made a Google Doc
and people started buying it and so we
had I opened a little like Shopify
storefront where people would order this
stuff online and then so I would know
exactly how much to make because a big
thing in food is like if it's it's
already so hard to make money and really
if you're not efficient in terms of
every decision of how much labor and
ingredient you'll really lose money so
by sort of taking my orders in advance I
knew exactly how much to make and
nothing was going to go to waste and
then people would come pick up their
stuff and so then very quickly it grew
from just pasta - pasta and sausages -
pasta and sausages and cookies because
everyone else that I knew who is an
unemployed cook who maybe wanted to
start their own food business also
wanted to do these things so we we
started doing this and all of a sudden
it became this like online marketplace
where you could pre-order and prepay for
your food and then come and pick up your
stuff like a week later I know it was
sort of this way to get beautiful
restaurant quality stuff at home but it
was before it was certainly before
caviar it was certainly before like a
lot of these internet food things and it
was also before good eggs which is like
a food tech startup that was sort of
born out of of this thing and so it was
definitely like one of the first online
like I don't know who order your food
thing I don't know it was just a weird
time and so then we had a mailing list
from the restaurant and I started to
sending it out to that and and very
quickly because the press sort of was
like very interested in this weird way
that I was operating this thing the
mailing list grew to like you know many
many tons of thousands of people way
more than I could report so it was just
it was it was the whole thing that grew
out of control the
the resources I had very quickly and so
I was always struggling to keep up and
that became such a source of stress and
all I had wanted to do was to make some
pasta I'm like managing like 9,000
business licenses and permits and Health
Department and you know taxes and sales
taxes and vendor infighting and people
wanting their beans vegan or whatever
like it was so much more than I ever
wanted to do and it took so much energy
and I couldn't do it anymore
and I knew I knew I couldn't do it
anymore so you have see you have this
feeling I can't do this anymore which I
think a lot of people have and yet they
keep doing it right for a long time and
maybe maybe forever
it's it to a certain extent now while
this is happening you have these
maternal instincts kicking in which make
you feel obligated on some level to help
these people who at least in your head
at some point and in their heads depend
on this income when do you remember like
the meal the drinks you had with a
friend the walk you took where you're
just like you know what [ __ ] it like I
have to I have to hello I have to close
this down when you went from thinking
about winding it down to like okay
tomorrow morning like that's it I'm
doing it
it was therapy okay all right I'm pretty
sure it was therapy and I'm pretty sure
I realized I think the like thought that
sort of like really hit my body that I
realized it was that I had by that point
spent 10 years cooking I had been
wanting to be a writer for you know
since I was 15 years old I finally had a
chance to like make the time to be a
writer I even had an office that I had
that I shared with other writer like I
had everything in place but because this
thing was ruining my life and making me
miserable I couldn't do the thing that I
always had wanted to
do and was like basically ready to do
and so and not that it was some easy
thing to just go be a writer cuz like
what I was gonna write I ended up
writing blog posts for yoga journal calm
for twenty five dollars like it wasn't
so much income or anything it was just
this I had this I knew that this thing
was making me like emotionally and
almost physically ill so I had I just
had to stop and I think in that now I'm
just so much more attuned to that moment
to that feeling of knowing like this
thing is bad for me you know and no
matter how many other people it's a good
for it's making me sick and it's making
me feel really bad so I think I I try to
be a lot more aware of that and
sometimes now I get into situations or
projects or jobs where like I that
feeling comes up again but I'm already
in it and often now a lot of the work
that I do is temporary you know like
it's a one I'd make I do one project I
do one article I do one story I do one
whatever so now for me it's more about
learning and being really attuned to
what's happening even just for example
in the process of making this show like
I had never made a show before this was
this incredible opportunity that came to
me I was so excited and felt so lucky to
go make it and go do it and and I still
feel so lucky and so excited but a lot
of things happened throughout the making
of the show that I was like oh this
doesn't feel very good or this doesn't
feel very fair or I don't ever want to
be in a situation like this again you
know and and so now that I know what
this situation what what's possible like
I know that when negatively and also
positively I know what to ask for and I
know how to articulate that and so you
know like I will forever insist you know
like to me I'm gonna insist on working
with a lot more people of color in the
future like I'm gonna insist on making
sure that I have a lot more power
creatively in anything that I do because
I realized I became very frustrated when
I didn't have as much power as I needed
or wanted so there are just things like
it's a constant learning
nothing's perfect we figure things out
as we go and and like we try to do our
best and like what is failure I don't
know I mean it's not that big of a deal
if especially if there's some sort of
positive takeaway that you have and
maybe my therapist would be really proud
of me maybe it's really bad for me to
even say that my therapist would be
proud of me but like but like but I do
feel like all of these stories and all
of these experiences really always come
back to me sort of paying attention to
my feelings mm-hmm yeah here here that's
that's something that I've also
personally been been working on because
I think I'm uted my feelings or viewed
them as a liability for so long and I've
I've realized holy [ __ ]
you cannot spreadsheet your way out of
everything I mean or into everything you
really have to pay attention to that I
mean I can I think about that all the
time like I came from a culture that's
like very much about sort of appearances
and not very touchy-feely in a lot of
ways I came from a family that wasn't
super touchy-feely I came so like what
did I learn to do I learned to shut down
all of my own feelings and then I made
myself I made my way into a profession
who literally tells you to shut down
your feelings like when you are a cook
in a restaurant you don't have time or
room or space for feelings like and not
only that not only emotional feelings
but if you actually burn or cut yourself
there's not time or space to address
that you just sort of wrap your hand up
and keep going so there's this way where
like I have have been trying to unravel
the many years of sort of emotional
shutdown that I have been conditioned to
be in and so now I'm like I'm gone I'm
like on way to the other end where I'm
like what is the feel you know I read
about Jill Soloway x' sets and she's the
director and creator of transparent and
I read about or the other day I was
listening to an interview with one of
the actors from Atlanta and I read about
these TV sets where everyone's real
touchy feely and like checks in with
each other all the time and like they
have an emotional check-in every morning
and and I'm like that's the kind of
place where I want to work like that I
just want to work where like
cameraman is like and we are crying
together you know if you are if if you
do have that experience I want to have a
follow-up conversation to see if you're
like okay that's my home or if you're
like you know what a pendulum swung too
far the other direction like I think I
want somewhere in the middle I can only
have half the camera people crying so
you you you have tackled so many
different projects in so many different
ways you've had some missteps you've
made your mistakes as we all have your
book was I at least from the outside
looking in I mean a real flag in the
ground that has allowed you to do a lot
of things and it's a very very it's a
very good book like I said it's one of
the few I keep in my kitchen and I'd
love to chat just a little bit about the
genesis because I think it was what
let's say around 2006 when you slip this
note to pollen when did when did your
book come out 20 last year what 17 okay
yeah and this is not a book that you
turned out really quickly you didn't
just assemble another cookbook which you
and I both know are just everywhere and
and it did make a mark so I I'm really
curious to know you're auditing this
class with Michael Pollan what are some
of the early ideas for the book or early
titles for the book that that never saw
the light of day so after I audited the
class with Michael he started writing a
book about cooking which ended up being
cooked so he asked me to teach him how
to cook so when I would come over to his
house we would cook together and talk
about cooking and I every week when I
went over there I'd bring over a
different book idea and there were so
many bad ones
stole many bad ones like I can't
remember all of them I do remember there
was one where I had this sort of mentee
employee who was kind of like this like
um bipolar gutter Punk what is a gutter
Punk Punk is like well we have a lot of
them in Berkeley um he he was just this
kind of punky kid who was like had all
the tattoos and listened to like you
know button like loud music I don't know
like he called himself a gutter Punk and
so he and he had a lot of like learning
disabilities and I had given up hope on
him as and I don't even know why we
hired him and eventually I just was like
I gave up such hope on him that I
couldn't look at him for I couldn't look
him in the eye for months and at some
point there was some moment that he had
where he turned himself around and he
came to work and suddenly I think it had
to do with taking honestly his his
mental health medication and so and so
he just like became this incredible
student and and I felt really bad for
not having been a better supporter of
his but then I also became motivated to
really teach him and support him
and this incredible moment was when he
came to work one day and he was like I
don't want you guys to be mad at me but
I you know I've been going to like
Community College and I signed up for a
study abroad program and I'm going to
Italy like and I was like we are not mad
at you no I was like this is the most
amazing thing that you like somehow went
from basically being nearly homeless
when you started coming here to caring
about food so much that you like signed
yourself up for Community College you
got yourself to go to Italy like this is
incredible and we're gonna help you as
much as we possibly can
so he was really this I learned probably
as much from him as he learned from me
and I was like I'm gonna write a memoir
of teaching Robin how to cook and
Michael is like that's a terrible idea
like nobody wants you know and then I
had this other idea where I was going to
write the Tartine After Hours cookbook
the like menu cookbook of all these
dinners that I had made that I was
making in 13 bakery and Michael was like
you know that's fine like
but I know you're thinking it's gonna be
easy and notebooks are easy and
eventually he would sit down yeah he's
just like there's no such thing as an
easy book yeah and so he said to me he
was like I know you know he would
interview me periodically so to get
quotes for his book and he said what's
the deal you're so obsessed with these
four elements and I was like oh yeah
salt fat acid he you know that's the
system that I used to teach myself to
cook I used to teach other people I
always thought I'd write a book about it
one day and he was like well there is
your book like that and I was like no no
no no no I was like that books gonna be
really hard to write it won't have
beautiful photos because it's not about
that kind of cooking and it just I can't
do that and he he's he just I remember
this so clearly he said listen like you
live in a delusional universe where
everyone who you know who's written a
successful book is already a celebrity
of some kind either celebrity chef or
like some famous writer and so you have
this really confused notion that book
and celebrity are somehow like tied
together or notoriety or something but
really what publishers want is a unique
and strong idea and that's what this is
I've never heard this before it makes so
much sense and so this is your book and
he's like stop messing around and go do
this look great and so I just felt the
weight of this like huge task being set
before me and and so you know and like I
said I didn't really have the tools in
the beginning I mean I sort of knew what
went to a book went into a book proposal
he sort of told me but I also knew that
this would look much different than any
book proposal he had ever written and so
I just sort of started going to my
office I've got a I got a writing
residency and I went to go figure this
out and that was writing residence you
know it's just like it was like an
opportunity to go write for two weeks
uninterrupted in a beautiful setting and
like be housed and fed and and that was
maybe a mistake to go so early in my
writing process because I wasn't really
writing I was still very much like it ei
ting so I just had like a wall of
post-it notes and then everyone
at the residence he would come down to
the dinner table and be like I wrote
5,000 words today and I'd be like I
always want to slap those people no no
offense if anyone listening is one of
those people they're like oh man
had a pretty tough day only knocked out
5,000 words what like I barely figured
out what you fought to use on the first
page I laid in a hammock a lot and um
and that first round like anything I
wrote during those two weeks I was that
was definitely at the time when I was
attempting to be Michael Pollan and so
eventually I realized that wasn't
working for me and so then and then I
tried for a short while to be another
writer and then that wasn't working
either and then eventually I was like oh
I just have to be myself
if you don't mind it's my friend
tomorrow Adler who's an incredible
writer she just has such a beautiful way
of writing that I very much enjoy
reading but it's not me you know and so
and and it's so good that I want it to
be my words but it's not my words and so
I had if I had to just be okay with
whatever comes out of my mouth or on you
know on to my page is my thing and I'm
still learning that like there are so
many times even when I got this get
column for The Times magazine which at
the time when I started cooking was
really like the highest sort of I don't
know like writing that was coming out
about food it was it's me it was like
the thing that I had always like dreamt
of was to be able to write the food
column for The Times magazine so I
couldn't believe it when it finally
became my job and I still can't really
believe it and I still have so much
terror every time I sit down to write it
where I'm like this is gonna be
published in the New York Times Magazine
oh my god like I'm not smart enough for
this and so I'm not good for this and so
then and there's this way where
sometimes I'll turn I'll just be lazy
and I can't figure out a different way
to say something so I'll write the silly
stupid way that I would say it and
that's the stuff the editors are always
like this is amazing you're so good and
I every time I'm like oh I thought
that's what you were gonna cut like
there was this one time when I said
something like hello my name is sameen I
basically wrote like hi my name is
Simeon and I'm an artisan bread hoarder
you know which is such a silly dumb
things
and she was like this is amazing and I
was like I don't and so eventually I had
to ask her I said why is it that you
always like this really silly stuff
that's not crafted you know and she said
because it's you and because like you're
here because we like your voice and so
the more true you can be to your own
voice the better that is and I said but
isn't that like the cheesiest possible
stuff I figured he would cut all those
like dumb jokes that I make and she said
you know maybe if it came from someone
else we would cut it but when it comes
from you it sounds so true to what how
you would actually talk or what you
would actually write that we it makes
sense for us to keep it and I said it is
how I actually talk she said yeah so
that's why we want it so I'm still
getting it through my head the thing
that people value about me is me you
know me trying to be of MacArthur Genius
or whatever legend you mentioned earlier
how Michael said to you something along
the lines of publishers are looking for
unique and clear ideas and I just want
to take that and expand it a bit because
for people who are listening you know I
would also say that what any audience or
potential audience the people out there
who are part of your tribe or who want
the version of you that is the true you
that you can put on the page also want
not just unique and clear ideas but they
want a unique and clear voice and that
I've had friends come to me who have
incredible stories and are well-spoken
but they say I'm not a writer I can't
write I don't know if I could ever tell
my story although people tell me I
should write a book I should do this I
should do that and that's a longer
conversation like whether you should
write a book or not is like if if for
whatever reason it exercises more demons
than like yours it pulls out of your
life than yes but but what I what I try
to convey and this was said to me
actually is that you don't need to be
John McPhee you don't need to be Michael
Pollan you don't need to be anyone who's
writing you admire so much that
intimidates you to actually be a good
writer if that makes any sense
like if you didn't you have a unique and
clear voice you can consistently be you
then you've won more than half the
battle and so if you if you don't know
how to use a semicolon it's fine like
it's not the most mature problem and
it's I think you accomplish that really
well in your book and I would be curious
to know as someone who has dabbled in
television a few times now what did you
find most rewarding and challenging
about the television format and and why
did you decide to say yes because you go
from a relatively solitary queen of the
castle environment when you're writing a
book now granted you have editors and so
on but it's kind of your gig right in a
lot of ways - holy [ __ ] who are all
these people what am I gonna do do i how
do I am I supposed to interact with
everybody how do I met it's it's a
completely different environment so why
did you decide to do TV and and what
were things that surprised you well in
terms of this like solitary versus
social I have always been both and which
is why I continue to cook because I
really enjoy both the manual like
physical part of it but also the really
communal part of it where I get to go be
in conversation and ask other people
what they're cooking and eating and
learn new things from other cooks so I
think I'd go bananas if I was only
sitting at a desk all day every day you
know so I enjoy having both things so to
me the decision to go work on some
collaboration that would bring me in to
you know work with a lot of people all
the time that really wasn't a negative
thing at all um and then I don't know
you know I was so excited I I was so
excited about the opportunity to bring
this philosophy of cooking to a broad
broad audience that that was ultimately
another thing that I was seeking and to
me I think after the first or second
cooking class I ever taught which I
think was around too
2006 or 2007 I remember coming to work
one day with my friends with these other
chefs and I said you know this is really
inefficient I was like Here I am like
teaching 12 ladies you know 12 wealthy
ladies how - I don't know use the right
amount of salt or whatever like how many
of these 12 person cooking classes am I
gonna have to teach before I actually
teach people you know a really broad
audience how this kind of fundamental
and really life-changing information it
seems like it's gonna be hard to reach a
large crowd plus just the economics of
it that like for my time and ingredients
and renting a kitchen or whatever it
wasn't inexpensive you know I had to
charge a lot of money and so that meant
that it was already like naturally
narrowing down the group of people to
whom I could you know teach this stuff
so I came in to work one day and I was
like I think if I had a TV show I think
if I had a cooking show where I taught
people how to cook I could reach so many
more people I could do it so much more
efficiently and it would really make a
difference and being Berkeley my two
friends were like that's a terrible idea
you are a terrible capitalist who you
know has totally totally like sold out
because the idea you know they're like
in Berkeley most people like don't have
television they don't let their kids
watch television so the idea that I
could possibly want to do television was
just like so sort of morally uncouth or
whatever and so that really sort of
stung me at the time but I now I
recently remembered I was like oh this
has been something I've thought about
and wanted for a long time so when the
opportunity to turn the book into a show
presented itself I was like yes this is
amazing I get to do something different
I think there's a lot of food TV out
there there's sort of two types of it
there's like the really accessible sort
of everyday cooking stuff that is
generally shot in a studio with like
not-so-great lighting and is is meant to
be sort of like getting you to make some
simple stuff at home and then there's
the really aspirational like cinematic
stuff like chef's table which is not so
much about cooking as it is sort of like
a
geography of a different chef and it's
really like aspirational and quite elite
and so I was really upset when I thought
about it that there was nothing that
existed that was beautiful and cinematic
but also accessible you know why didn't
something exist at the intersection of
these two things and so I knew that I
wanted to make something gorgeous and
just inspiring and but also be for
everyone and there were ways in which
like that was very easy for me to
translate because I had already been
distilling those ideas into the book and
into the way I wanted the book to look
and the vision I had for the way the
book would be in the world and function
in people's lives and then there were
entirely new things that I had to learn
throughout the process of because I've
never made a show before
so one of the things that I like looking
back after having gone through both all
of the pre-production and then 40 weeks
of like production and post-production
I mean I kept saying to people they'd be
like when will you have time I was like
imagine I'm pregnant
40 weeks like imagine I'm pregnant call
me when the baby's born because like
that's how intense this thing is going
to be and so they the one of the things
that I did not anticipate but realized
pretty quickly that I was so good at and
I really enjoyed doing was I for some
weird reason I don't know why I have
this like ability to ignore the cameras
and just be me like I don't change at
all and so there's a way people kept
saying oh you're a natural you're a
natural and so I think that's what they
were referring to was that I'm the exact
same on-camera as I am off-camera and I
had to learn you know some basic things
like where to stand and what's light and
where do I look and where do I not look
but one more that was great perfect one
more for safety
I also because I'm a perfectionist would
take it really personally at first real
and I'd be like oh no I did it wrong I
have to do it again and pretty quickly I
realized oh we're doing it again and it
has nothing to do with me doing it right
or wrong it's because they need a
different angle or he messed something
the sound guy messed something you know
third
so many variables so the way that like I
could deliver the energy hi every time
but you know and that was that was stuff
that I guess isn't something everyone
has so I had that so that was great and
then can I pause for one second also I
think that and this is pure speculation
but you've taught so much I think that
you I think that you honed that ability
also in the process of teaching I just
I've seen that overlap for for some
folks so I don't know how much of it is
nature versus nurture but yeah I
definitely think for sure and also even
just cooking itself cooking is a
repetition right like cooking is
everyday you come in and do the thing
again whether you did it perfectly
yesterday or really badly yesterday and
so and there's you just have to put your
head down and do it again and so I I
feel like there were certain like I
don't know calluses that I had formed
just from my other jobs that made made
me be like ready to be good at this
but it's funny that there were so many
things I didn't know because I had never
done it before and also nobody explained
to me and so there in retrospect I'm
like because maybe I am a teacher who
likes to put people at ease and explain
things to them throughout the process
there would be these things that I would
learn like distill and articulate and
then at the next day the next shoot the
next time we were with someone else I
would be able to explain this because we
were going around the world and bringing
all sorts of different people onto the
screen with us and so and almost none of
them had ever been on camera before and
you know we show up with this crew of 25
people and all these trucks and all this
equipment and lighting it's so much
stuff and it's so overwhelming for
people and especially in some of the
places that we went where it was really
off the beaten path like very rural
places in Japan and in Mexico and so I
kept trying to do it's that beginner's
mind thing where I'm like okay how do I
put myself in this person's shoes and
imagine what it feels like to have this
whole like rodeo show up you know it's
like a circus and so and what what what
is not making you feel like and when you
know when it's not explained to these
guys
oh we're gonna have to do everything 17
times but it's not cuz you did it wrong
you know so the things that I learned
along the way I would say to everyone
like don't worry like we have to do it a
lot of times but it has nothing to do
with you you're perfect you're fine or
just look at me like don't look at them
or there's a lot of sort of talking in
the background that you have to tune out
and a lot of the time they're calling
your name because they're talking to
each other about focusing the camera on
you so I had to be like just ignore if
you if you hear your name they're not
talking to you you know because you're
natural human response is to turn so
there are these like little things that
I learned that made it easier for me and
then I I took a great pleasure in being
the guide for whoever we were sort of
because it's my job to put that person
that that grandma I'm cooking with at
ease so that she can be her best self
and we can get like the best footage
from her and it's I don't know it's that
maternal thing or whatever it's that
teacher thing and um I realized that I
was really good at that
and so I I yeah and it was just nice to
have an entirely new field an entirely
new skill to hone in terms of just like
what is it to be on camera what is it to
like work with these different people
that part was really fun I really really
enjoyed it I'm really excited for you
and I'm also really excited for
everybody to see this I'm excited
can you just just to look at the the
overall structure of the of the show how
many episodes are there total there's
four episodes and each one's about like
50 ish minutes long and it it sort of
matches the structure of the book so
there's salt fat acid and heat and in
each episode we go to a different
country to sort of explore the nuances
of that element but then through
voiceover and storytelling and a
beautiful archival imagery like really
our our team who was digging up the
archival did such a good job we're able
to connect everything back to some sort
of a universal message of you know like
I couldn't we went to Japan for salt but
honestly we could have gone to any
country for salt we went to Italy for
fat we could have gone anywhere for fat
so it's this way we're like
through the specific I find a way to
then connect it to the universal and I
do I my hope for the show and what I
think from like early small feedbacks
that I'm receiving is that what I wanted
it to do was to give you a few little
nuggets that you could like put in your
pocket and like same as the book never
have to return to the book never have to
return to the show never have to like
refer to me again and that these are
going to be the little things that
change the way that you cook and so from
what I've heard is that people are doing
it like they're doing the stuff I told
them to do you know so if you know I
think especially or like where Netflix
is concerned there's so much beautiful
like food documentary and food this and
even like food competitions on there but
I think this is the first show that is
really sort of aimed to like get you
cooking you know I'm so excited yeah I
need a reboot I've been I have I mean I
do enjoy cooking but this this I think
is is such a fun culturally rich way to
do it so I want let me ask you as people
are listening to this in there and
they're getting excited to not only see
these various locations and cultures and
learn from you as you're pulling them
into these stories salt fat acid heat so
I read somewhere I think it was on the
kitchen comm that is one of your
indulgences and maybe you've changed you
can feel free to change is a local olive
oil meaning local to you over on the
west coast from Katz winery and then
there are few other things could you
recommend people who want to just grab a
few tools oh yeah you know there's no
budget limit but we're not gonna be
buying you know the latest and greatest
super expensive you know immersion
circulator or something but like with
something are there a handful of things
maybe they overlap like a nice salt like
some type of fat acid but anything that
you can think of that most home cooks
may have neglected her or not
incorporated that people can just run
out and grab in preparation
yes okay oh this is exciting okay for
salt I think that Maldon salt which is a
British salt that the little pyramid
flakes that comes in a little white box
yeah that is now more readily available
in grocery stores but also you can buy
it on Amazon and I feel like that not
only tastes amazing but it has this
incredible texture that you just putting
a little bit on top of cookies or even
ice cream is amazing but also any salad
or tomato toast I don't know I have a
huge jar of it that I just reach into
all the time at home I'm so good it's so
good I think one thing that I learned
about on the show that sort of blew my
mind is that I really hope will will
catch on after this show is how
different and how far superior a good
soy sauce is to regular soy sauce like
the regular everyday sort of Kikkoman
and and the way you know it's a good one
is that it's been aged in a wooden
barrel versus a stainless steel tank so
often it'll say like wooden wooden
barrel age or barrel aged on the thing
there's a brand probably the brand
that's easiest to come by in the States
is called nama shoyu mm-hmm and again
you can buy that on Amazon and so but
it's also like probably in like
higher-end stories I've also seen it at
Whole Foods and it's a little bit it's
like nine dollars versus 250 you know
but it's one of those things the flavor
is so much richer and so much deeper and
like bounces off all of the sort of like
angles of your mouth it's amazing it's
so incredible and so I would say that
soy sauce is really special
olive oil wise yeah I would say Katz
olive oil is really delicious and also
there's another one that's local to here
to us in California called Seca Hills
which is made on an Indian Reservation
and so it's like amazing
Seca like dried SEK a OS okay yeah and
those two are some two of their like
nicest California olive oils and Seca
Hills is actually I think relatively
expensive inexpensive and you can buy it
in bigger things so that's kind of my
everyday olive oil now
and then acid wise I mean I love a lime
it's my favorite but if you're gonna buy
again vinegar wise I think a nice rice
vinegar is really delish
like I'm just discovering how much more
delicious you know I tried in my recipe
testing I try to cook with the everyday
stuff that you can buy at any grocery
store so that it my recipes are pretty
accurate to like what anybody's gonna
make anywhere in the country instead of
rent like very specific niche
ingredients but sometimes you know when
I'm making my own dinner at home I just
want to have like the delicious rice
vinegar so that same brand nom nom I
show you they make a really delicious
rice vinegar that's just so fantastic
and they're yeah so that's a really good
one and then heat is really oh here this
is a luxury this is a little bit
expensive but it's the most amazing the
most amazing so I would say like you
always want to have a great pan and so
for me I'm generally I often say just
how the cast iron pan it's the most used
pan in my house as a cast iron and I
bought at a flea market for like 25
bucks but if you want to graduate up
from a cast iron there is a company in I
believe they're in Virginia it's called
blank creatives be Lanc they make these
beautiful hand forged pans that are
they're steel there's some sort of a
cast steel there like that have this
beautiful bluish tint and they this pan
is unbelievable my best friend gave me
one for a gift a few years ago and for
whatever reason I didn't start using it
really regularly until recently it blows
my mind how good it is because it Browns
just like a cast iron pan and but it
heats up it's much lighter it heats up a
lot more quickly and and it just it
retains its heat there just a delight to
use these pans are a delight to use I
have no I don't know how else to say it
like and it just everything that comes
out of it is so good do you cook
everything or can you cook for instance
if would you cook eggs in this or would
you happen it
yeah and your eggs wouldn't stick
nothing would like because it's
definitely has a seasoning that you have
to keep up you know and it will rust it
will rust even a little bit more easily
like sometimes if I don't dry mine
really well out in the morning there'll
be a little rust forming so I have to
wipe it away but it's that seasoning
that makes it so beautiful and perfectly
nonstick they're also just takes very
gorgeous and look like a beautiful
handmade object and they're you know I
think they're in the $200 range but like
a pan I don't know people buy the la
cruz de pots for 300 bucks and they use
them for 30 years so I feel I feel okay
giving a one expensive pan sure and by
seasoning or you say like heating it up
putting salt in it and like kind of
scratching the surface or is it really
just letting it absorb the various oils
and so on yeah it's just a fact that it
like it's a I I'm not so good with the
science of metal and these pans and
stuff but I think that what happens is
as you cook or if you intentionally like
rub it with some fat and then put it in
the oven and let it get warm
the fats like turn into Nepal it's
called I think polymerization and so the
fats sort of almost like fill in the
little any holes that might be in the
metal like invisible minut holes and
then create a really smooth surface and
so that smooth the smoother that surface
is the more nonstick the thing will be
which is why you know when you buy a
cast iron that's not yet seasoned if you
even touch it with your fingers you can
feel that it's a little bit pebbly in
there you know and that publius is where
things stick is it like that pebble enos
is stick to sticking stuff and Teflon
exists at the complete other end of the
range where there's it's like almost
entirely smooth so the smoother the
thing is the less sticking you'll have
here here well I mean I think that this
is this I think this is an exciting
place to probably tie up I encourage
everybody to check out the book and the
show of course they can find you on the
interwebs that's Instagram and Twitter
at ciao sameen or salmon now I'll just
say something to keep it easy but
yeah chalice I mean CIA Oh semion on the
serum Twitter on Facebook
/so mean dot nose rat and then assault
fat asset heat comm is where they can
find information about the TV show as
well on that at the earth everything and
all the wonderful people I'm like
writing profiles of all the people that
we got to meet so you can learn more
about the people from the show when
there's when the website launches yeah
mm-hmm and I will also link to
everything we've talked about in the in
the show notes as per usual for folks so
people listening you can go to Tim dot
blog forward slash podcast for links to
everything we've discussed including the
show at the products the books
everything and the email to Michael
Pollan that's right and if you can find
at the actual the actual wordsmithing
that you used with Michael Pollan I
would love to see that so I'll put that
in the show notes if we can find it is
there anything else you would like to
say or ask of people listening or
suggest to people listening before we
before we wrap up gosh no happy cooking
or salt don't forget the lime all your
feelings then don't forget you're
feeling what what a gift to spend time
with you thank you so much and thanks so
much this was so like emotionally
resonant and fun and just really
beautiful so thank you my pleasure
entirely this this is maybe maybe my
therapy is doing this podcast that's my
version of therapy
well once again really appreciate you
taking the time today the the show looks
beautiful I really hope people check it
out and to be continued I hope we have
many more conversations need 0 Tim thank
you and to everybody listening as always
and until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books fresh books has become the go-to
cloud accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advise and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid to track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast the new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things tracking your time the quick
proposals that I mentioned formatting
free super-easy late payment reminders
so you don't have to chase people
mattad expensives sharing files and
messages with your clients award-winning
customer service they are extremely
responsive the interface is super
intuitive and there's almost no learning
curve so in short it's easy it's save
you time and right now fresh books is
offering an unrestricted 30-day free
trial for all of my listeners to claim
yours check it out go to freshbooks
dot-com forward slash tim and enter tim
ferriss in the how did you hear about a
section and that is funky spell t IM fe
r RI SS so again go to fresh books comm
forward slash tim and enter tim ferriss
and how did you hear about us section
check it out i get asked all the time if
you could only use one supplement what
would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens to try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a 100 Allah values so if you
buy athletic greens you get an extra
$100 and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash tim
again thats athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase